As expected, hurry up and enter Do
n't use it as a shield If
there are few people, should I sit in the backmost?
The fact that a simple mechanism floats up The
detailed depiction
of the mysterious anti-gravity device and the animation depiction that you can see like pushing a car whose engine is difficult to
start This process creates a sense of reality.
Leisurely Hall where you can run and return The
main character's reliable ability
This feeling of giganticness
First of all, a small flying boat type that passes by repeatedly You can see that the propulsive force is working with the paper in the air
This wind pressure  Kan
Ah, even if I lean diagonally and run, I'll be swept away and I can't say it here, but I'll do it with persuasive power
.  This vogue girl, who has the world as a character
, says it as it is. It's painful to open more than I asked
for.